[Music]
thank you
hey everybody what's going on it's
Sunday and we're talking about another
movie this is a good one
yeah remember when yeah when we did the
original Bella Lugosi uh Universal
Dracula we mentioned on there that there
was a Spanish language version which was
shot pretty much simultaneously like on
the same set same costume same script
everything like that and we discovered
that to be had the Spanish language
version also yeah you can see it for
free on there so we watched that one as
well because that was like really really
curious to compare the two of them
Spanish Dracula
it's fast Dracula same sets everything
it's a universal picture too yeah and um
watched it and in some ways a better
movie than the Amer than the American
version or the English version now it
doesn't have Baylor Lugosi in it
which that's a strike against it
but the actor that they have play in
Dracula in this he has his own take on
the character and I liked it I liked him
as Dracula and there's a lot of special
effects in this one that were cut out of
the other one a lot of little story
details were cut out
this is a good movie
you know you want to see both of them
you want to see both of them yeah but I
think that's really cool and I think I
mentioned this like on because I feel
like the Spanish language I think most
people know about it now like you know
or more than they used to but see the
thing about it was that they thought
that the Spanish language Dracula was
lost for a really long time so it was
only like super horror nerds like you
know going back to the 60s and 70s that
remembered anything about it and like I
said they thought that had been lost and
then in New Jersey like in a warehouse
or something back in the 70s they found
like a partial print of it I think some
of it had like rotted away and stuff but
they actually showed it I think at like
the Museum of Modern Art and interest
kind of got uh you know kind of
reignited after that and then finally
later on in the 90s I think in Cuba they
actually found
um a whole print of it that was all
intact and at that point Universal
decided they were gonna release it
you're because you remember like on VHS
back in the 90s when they did that big
like Universal monsters collection yeah
and they so they decided to include it
with that and they were actually
surprised like how many orders they got
for it like how many people were curious
and like wanted to see it once they
figured out like um you know all of the
background behind it so from that point
forward I believe like now if you buy
like the universal monster like set or
whatever uh then it'll have this on
there as well
but I just like I said it's cool because
you don't really get I know that
Universal did this for a few years like
back in the late 1920s and early 1930s
like when sound films first started
getting like real widespread they didn't
really have like the dubbing the same
kind of dubbing technology that they
would have nowadays because nowadays
they just make a movie and then they
just dub different you know tracks over
it which is like much less you know uh
expensive obviously but before they
could really do that what they would
normally do was what they did in this
case where it's like you'd have the sets
and then whatever language they thought
you know whatever country they wanted to
sell this particular movie in they would
use all the same sets the same script
the same costumes everything like that
but then they would get those speaking
actors like and they would just like
shoot it at around the same time you
know what I mean like using all the
stuff and and then they would you know
so they'd make like multiple versions
but as far as I know this is what like
really the only one that's got super
famous and I think that because they
didn't do very well I think this was one
of the last times that they did this
before they just said [ __ ] it we're
going to dubbing because that's cheaper
right but so it's really weird it's and
it's I got kind of like fascinated by
this because here's two movies working
from the same script but it's like a
different cast and different directors
so different edit a different cut yeah
shots are done differently it's
fascinating
the characters are interpreted in
different ways
um because the censorship issues were
different in in the Spanish-speaking
World they didn't have to cut a bunch of
special effects out uh they allowed you
to see stuff happen so uh I think to a
certain extent there's more of the
brides in there a few a few seconds of
them
um the guy who does Renfield knocks it
out of the park he's [ __ ] he's a
lunatic and he's got yeah he's like way
over the top
Dracula has a lot more lines
um he does more stuff it the the
script is more coherent because it's not
as edited so like they tell you what
happened to Lucy uh for yeah yeah they
did they told you that they yeah they
don't show it they don't show it but
they do actually like tell you there's a
scene where they say you know we're
gonna have to go do that and then later
on they're like yeah that sucks that we
had to do that like pretty much
um whereas the English version let's
left you hanging another thing is
there's Dynamic shots in this uh they
actually move through Castle Dracula and
Carfax Abby you get to see the flying
what they call Flying buttresses if you
see how 3D that set really was I mean it
was an expensive set and in in the
English version it's very static the way
it's shot it might as well just be a 2d
[ __ ] stage like something off a damn
play or it may as well be like a map
painting you know but in this one you
see that no it's it's a location it's
good real good
um
what's the actor's name who plays
dracula in this um his name is Carlos uh
via
various okay yeah okay well Carlos does
a great hopefully I'm pronouncing that
Carlos does a great job as Dracula it's
a different interpretation
um it's it's he's still he's using a lot
of stuff that you'd use in silent film
uh yeah more exaggerated facial
expressions yes facial expressions are
more exaggerated Tammy asks is this on
2B also yes it is yeah yes it is it's um
he kind of comes off a little bit more
like uh The Phantom of the Opera if you
see any scenes with the Phantom of the
Opera yeah I see him yeah I see what
you're getting at and I think maybe he
saw a Phantom of the Opera so he's gonna
I'm gonna go in that direction and what
it ends up being is it almost ends up
being kind of reminiscent of Gary
oldman's uh Dracula back when he's uh in
uh Turco what do you call turkos Vista
where was it uh he was it was volocia
but um yeah I think he called it
turkovista at the time that he you know
he was in there but he's just kind of a
trying to be a friendly host and tried
to act normal but this due date normal
you know there's a lot of good [ __ ] in
it that's cut out of the English version
it's just more it's a more of a complete
story
and I like this Dracula I like that I
like Carlos's interpretation of Dracula
it's a vampire yeah it's a lot different
like you said and some people I think
that people that come at it from like oh
maybe like a little bit of criticism or
saying it's like oh it's a little bit
like cheesier or it's a little kind of
goofy but I mean I can see that but it's
just like a different take you know what
I mean yeah he's coming off he's doing
he's doing what Lon Chaney's senior
which I believe that's who the Phantom
of the Opera was I think it was Lon
Chaney's dad right
oh now I can't remember Jake he's it's a
mixture of Phantom of the Opera
and Nosferatu I don't know if he saw
Nosferatu was announceratu already saved
and in circulation by the time this was
around yeah you know what
um
because some of the stuff he's doing is
very kind of yeah something like out of
NASCAR is that something like Nosferatu
came out in the nights in 1921 or 1922
but then there was all that you know
about like how it was supposed to be
destroyed I mean I'm assuming that
people saw it at the time like in the
1920s like before the lawsuits and
everything because he's holding his
mouth in a way to where you can see his
front teeth and it looks like we have
nosprato had little rat teeth yeah he's
more rat-like uh then Bela is Baylor's
kind of and he hadn't seen Baylor's
performance evidently I'm not sure if he
did because I was watching a couple
different because there's a couple
videos like on YouTube where they're
like comparing the two most of them say
um just the director and the
cinematographer I think watched the
rushes from the Todd Browning English
language version because they would
shoot during the day and then this crew
would come in at night and they would
watch like the dailies now some of the
things said that that actor
um the guy that played Dracula in the
Spanish language version Carlos that he
was the only actor that was allowed to
watch the Bella Lugosi one but then I've
also seen some sources say that like
none of the none of the actors watched
the other ones so I'm not really sure
what the truth is like I don't know if
they basically said hey do it like Bella
Lugosi or Blick with your own thing or
what he is not copying Lugosi he's not
though yeah it's his own take on it and
I like it
to me it's it feels more like like I
said Phantom of the Opera and Nosferatu
I think maybe he had seen Nosferatu or
he had read something about
vampires being kind of beastial and kind
of rat like and kind of it's
creepy you know because he he's doing
that
and it's more of a retro acting style
more like from the silent film era
but then the way the movie shots more
futuristic the camera's moving
and it it [ __ ] wobbles when it moves
they don't give a [ __ ] they're walking
across the damn floor well I mean those
cameras were much much bigger like and a
lot more unwieldy yeah than they are
nowadays but it's effective it is camera
move it is
yeah they didn't really I mean
especially during and a lot of people
will point this out like in the
comparison like in the English language
version like the introduction of Dracula
like when you first see him like come
down the stairs or whatever it's kind of
like it's a cool shot but it's just
really static like you just have Bella
Lugosi like walking down the stairs and
then here's Renfield I keep wanting to
say Harker because that's what it is in
the book but it's Renfield and uh you
know he doesn't notice him at first and
then he turns around and he's like what
what you know what I mean so is that but
in the Spanish language version they
actually do a bat flies into the castle
and kind of goes up here and then
Dracula like kind of comes out like
implying that he just like turned into a
bat yeah and then like there's a dolly
shot like up the stairs like that and
it's like so it's a lot more like I said
it's a lot more Dynamic like the
movement which I thought like was a lot
more effective in that way yeah and then
there's a deleted scene in here that is
kind of implied only a little bit in in
the English version
when
Renfield goes up the stairs to meet the
cow the cow walks towards him and goes
through a giant spider web yeah and
greets him they talk for a little bit
and then he turns around and walks right
back through that giant spider web
without breaking it without breaking it
and it doesn't feel it's like how the
[ __ ] did he do that
and he he has to go through it but he
breaks it
so it was uh that wasn't in the they did
it in the English language version but
it was very it was so subtle that if you
weren't really looking for it you
probably wouldn't even notice yeah it
makes a bigger deal of it than this it's
in this it's a bigger deal like it's
much more obvious that the vampire like
walks through so I kind of feel like in
the Spanish language version they make
it very clear like from the get-go that
he's Supernatural yeah whereas in the
English language one he's not as
Supernatural they turn that they turn
that special effect into like a
miniature scene and it's very effective
yeah very effective
suspense-filled scene
Ren feels like how the [ __ ] did he walk
through that without breaking it yeah
they made a bigger deal yeah and like I
said I think the only reason that I
noticed it in the English language
version was because somebody had told me
that the Spanish language version like
made a bigger deal out of that like
because I don't think I would have
noticed it otherwise yeah you know what
I mean because in the English it is in
there but because like I said it's the
same script but a lot of it was I think
we mentioned this like on the when we
were talking about the Lugosi Dracula
but the Spanish language version is
about half an hour longer there's a lot
more stuff in there it's a more complete
story
there it's a must-see you know if you if
you've seen Bella goes to draculate you
got to see this one too it's a great
supplement yeah because I just find it
so interesting that it's like and one
thing too that I think and okay so one
of the major things like I said and
we've talked about this when we were
talking about the Bella Lugosi one is
that they left Lucy hanging like I said
yeah um you know basically they did go
into the whole thing about Lucy like
attacking the kids or whatever
um you know but then I don't think in
the English language version they don't
mention her again I think like you kind
of see her wandering around in the thing
but they don't say oh hey we got a
killer or they don't mention killing her
they just kind of like forget about it
whereas in the Spanish language version
they don't show them killing her like
staking her but they do have a scene
where Van Helsing and I think Harker are
talking and they're like yeah we gotta
go do that and then like like much later
on in the movie they come out
um of like the cemetery or whatever and
they're just like man that's that's not
what they say they don't say man that
sucks but I'm just saying they're all
like downbeat it's like well we released
her soul or whatever so they did
actually like resolve that there's an
another scene too and it's almost
identical like in the English language
version there's a scene where Renfield
like crazy Renfield is in the thing like
in um doctor I guess it's Dr Stewart's
house right is in Dr Seward's house and
the maid passes out and Renfield like
crawls over to her and it looks like
he's gonna bite her or kill her or
something like that in the English
language version they cut away and so
you're like well what happened there
like did he kill her what the [ __ ] but
then like a scene or two later like the
maid is fine so you're not really sure
well what was that all about in the
Spanish language version they let that
scene play out and it's kind of like it
was almost like a gag like what they did
was she passed out and then renfield's
like crawling toward her all menacingly
like something's gonna happen and then
it's almost like a joke like there's
like a fly and he's like opens off where
he tries again and he tries to catch it
so it's like the fact that they didn't
put that in the English language version
I wonder if you people were confused
like wait I thought he killed the maid
why is she still walking around and
she's fine in the next scene but they
explained it in the Spanish language
version he didn't kill her it was just
like a gag the Spanish cast is Top Notch
the the Renfield that they got he's
great he's good he's got a different
interpretation of the character yeah he
is a maniac but he's made yeah but he's
got a lot more lines I think oh yeah
than the other one yeah he says a lot of
really cool [ __ ] that kind of explains
certain things that the English Renfield
said
like the English reading field said that
he saw
approaching him in the darkness what
looked like flames and as it got closer
he saw Dracula riding on top of the
Flames but the Flames were millions of
tiny little red eyes of rats
and then Dracula's eyes were just like
the rats but bigger yeah the Spanish
version
he gives more detail
you find out why he has so much grip
over over Renfield Dracula promises him
all the blood of all those rats to
sustain him for [ __ ] centuries so
that's why he's super jacked about yeah
so that's what Redfield was doing all
this [ __ ] for the blood of rats all
right so that was quite a deal that he
he had worked out with with Dracula
um
so and he uh did some other stuff about
uh saving his soul uh he said a bunch of
stuff about Lucy
and Mina and how they had to be saved
and he called them all a bunch of liars
and he would never [ __ ] betray
Dracula he didn't know Dracula he's
backing up he's talking himself in
circles it's good
uh another uh cast member that stood out
was the Spanish van helsig he's good
he's real good yeah
um he's just kind of a Spanish heavy uh
just kind of a gravitas type older guy
he's not skinny like the uh the the
English one I like the English version
too they're both good it's just a
different take on that character the
Spanish uh the Spanish man helsink
actually I think he does a little bit
more too doesn't he yeah the C that's
the thing it's like the scenes are much
longer they're longer and some people
are kind of like I I can see how maybe
people think like the English language
version one is paced better because it's
much shorter yeah um because some of the
scenes are like very very long and very
talky like in the Spanish version
because like they said they didn't cut
them shorter but in a lot of ways I
don't know I kind of preferred that
maybe yeah because I think maybe the
English language when maybe they took
out like a little bit too much I think
they did because some of the stuff that
they're talking about is important to
the story and it makes sense of why the
scene is going that way when you see the
Spanish version because it's a longer
edit and the story is more more coherent
um the Spanish the Spanish uh Van
Helsing uh kind of is more Brave he
comes off as being more Brave more
defiant to uh to Dracula also he has
great what the [ __ ] face yeah he's got a
lot of what the [ __ ] face
like I really like his facialism now I
do kind of prefer the English come here
[ __ ] yeah that is like
Baylor's witch I mean he's kind of owns
that role yeah yeah he's like he's much
creepier yeah he's a lot scarier yeah I
think the the
Bella is [ __ ] very much about
gravitas and that accent you know what I
mean in English it sounds really cool
and he's
playing that that character pretty
straight you know this guy
Dracula's more kind of like a the
Spanish track is a little bit closer to
Nosferatu
he's creepy sometimes it comes off as
Clowny a little manic little man like
his eyes are real big yeah he's high
strung yeah he's high strung but
Nosferatu kind of came off looking that
way in in some of the silent scenes with
his eyes all bugged out
he does have a
sounds like he does have a Romanian
accent in Spanish so I I give him props
to that
um
Mina and Lucy were different in the in
in the Latin they're Latin girls so they
have black hair it looks real goth uh
they're they're more shapely than the uh
uh American actresses and the outfits
are a lot more suggestive way more
cleavage more cleavage tighter more
which goes to show that in Latin culture
they they they liked thick you know what
I mean looking but even back then the
hourglass figure low cut black hair and
I thought it would look good and the
um
other than that the characters were
about the same I don't didn't notice any
big difference between them Mina had
more they don't call her Mina she called
me Ava okay now I think either Ava I
think because Mina Pride doesn't
translate well in Spanish in Portuguese
Mina sounds like Mina which means mine
and then in in Brazil sometimes they
could say Mina so quickly it sounds like
they said Mina yeah and Mina might be
mine in Spanish I'm not sure they're
real close yeah so maybe it was like an
actual word so they had to change your
name because you're running around
calling her mine mine mine mine that
would really [ __ ] up yeah that's a
Spanish dialogue what's that that
wouldn't make anything that made any
sense thank you camp guy Camp guy gave
us a Super Chat thank you that's the
T-shirt I gotta have not really sure
which one it was what one but what a
what [ __ ] face oh okay well that one
maybe I don't know who's that one the
ocp one I don't know yeah I designed
that one I'm gonna say I like the
Spanish language Mina slash Eva better
than the English language version
she has a little bit more lines she has
more lines and she's more
Helen Chandler plays her plays Mina in
the English language version and she's
great she's beautiful but she's a little
bit she's very icy and she's kind of
both her and Harker in the English
language version are kind of more
more stayed you know what I mean they're
just kind of like
um they're very like low-key kind of
like you know upper class English you
know what I mean they're very like
restrained and subdued whereas I kind of
feel like the Spanish language versions
of Mina and Harker who they actually
like I said call Juan and Eva or Ava
um they're a lot more they seem a lot
more like organic a lot more animated
and I think that works a little bit
better and I'm gonna say too that the
scene where
um like where they're out on the patio
or whatever after Mina has already been
bitten by the count and she's like super
into it like talking about how much she
loves Lin nighttime and everything
um that scene she they actually show her
biting like trying to bite Harker which
they don't show in the in the English
language version in the English language
version Mina just like looks at him like
all creepy and kind of like comes in
like that but then they cut away yeah
whereas in the Spanish language version
she's like oh she's like hugging on him
and like laughing maniacally and then
like she actually like bites him on the
neck I forgot and then like you know Van
Helsing and everybody are like horrified
like oh my god oh and also like her
dress is like way down here and like you
can see all the boob and everything like
that too yeah no they're giving down
blouses and stuff oh big time which they
wouldn't have done that in 31 in in an
English film but you know the Latinos
were ahead you know yeah they knew how
to they knew how to get [ __ ] asses
into seats yeah all their nightgowns
were a lot more revealed I mean not a
lot more of you I mean they're not
walking around like half naked or
anything like that it is still the 1930s
yeah but they were a lot more I mean
compared to the ones in the English
language version they were a lot more uh
revealing a lot like lower cut yeah you
wouldn't have got away with that in the
English language
they were
um trying to think of what else was uh
somebody mentioned the um the breaking
the mirror scene like where Van Helsing
like first sees yes bow yeah so like
yeah in a way I kind of prefer the
English language version because I kind
of think it was more it was more
restrained but I think that worked
better like you know because Bella
Lugosi just kind of like smacks the it's
a cigar box or music box or whatever it
is and he like slap kind of just slaps
it out of his hand like that like oh
sorry I don't like mirrors whereas in
the Spanish language version
he's like Wham like it's a lot more like
over the top I liked both yeah I think
both scenes fit the interpretation of
the characters that the actors had in
other words below's response was correct
uh Carlos's response was correct because
they fit the characters yeah there were
differences in the characters
Carlos is not as restrained he's more
it's a broader it's a much broader
performance it's more open he's he's
more manic like he said a lot more hyper
all right
but in Eerie well not Eerie would be
because Siri kind of didn't he he's
creep he's a creep you know he's not
yeah he comes across as like Les Schwab
yeah he's not that swab and more like
kind of I don't know if scuzzy or sleazy
or something yeah something I guess I'm
not sure if they're like the right
what's that
that fits with a Romanian description of
a Nosferatu they weren't [ __ ] sexy
[ __ ] they were
corpses that came out of the [ __ ]
ground and they were in their funeral
robes and [ __ ] and [ __ ] they were
nasty they were rats basically they're
described as rats
oh another thing that's different too is
um the way they come out the coffin yeah
like because they actually show like in
the English language version they show
like the coffin cut they open like open
them from the back like you can't see
nobody get now but it's just kind of
like opens like that and then the camera
like dollies away like to a stained
glass window or some [ __ ] and then it
dollies back and then Bella Lugosi is
going like he just got out of there yeah
whereas in the Spanish language version
the coffin opens at a whole bunch of
like Mist comes out yeah it's effective
and then light and a Mist yeah so it's
like it looks like like I said a lot
more Supernatural it's kind of like a
teleportation thing or something Genie
comes out of the bottle kind of like
that
yeah it looks good it looks good they
did a couple little gags like that yeah
he came out like I don't I mean either
neither one I mean I'm sure they just
had the actors you know both actors just
kneeling down behind the cop because
like I said climbing out of a coffin is
not you don't look real cool doing that
so there's two disappointing things
about the Spanish edit
and they're they're all they're also in
the in the English one there's no Lucy
death scene
yes they're not in either one they're
not neither one I guess they couldn't
show that because that would have been
like way too upsetting they should have
showed him killing Lucy yeah but you
could cut her head off evidently I think
that's what it was in the book well they
staked or anything and I think they put
Wolf's Bane in her mouth too if I'm
remembering correctly it's been a long
time since so they should have a scene
where they go down the Crypt and do that
yeah and then also the final
confrontation with Dracula it's too easy
they open the damn coffin and he's
laying in there he doesn't even wake up
they're sitting there talking about him
[Laughter]
he should have been Dracula should have
been fighting back as soon as the coffin
was open or and they don't actually show
the staking they think they used a
little bit of a uh uh didn't they didn't
they didn't the camera angle away well
the Spanish language version shows more
shows more a lot more
um the English like now the English
language version The Bella Lugosi
version was really anticlimactic
um basically they shot it from like it's
almost a long shot yeah and you can't
even really see I don't even think you
can see it's been like a few days since
we watched it but you know you just kind
of see
um Van Helsing like from the back
and he just kind of like leans over like
that and then they cut away to Mina
and Mina's sitting there going oh oh you
know what I mean like she's psychically
like feeling this the staking but they
don't like show anything and honestly
for a long time like I think when they
first did the movie like there are some
sound effects of like Bella Lugosi going
like oh oh you know what I mean like
they're staking him but I think for a
long time they took that out because
they thought it would be too upsetting
like it has been restored like the
version that's on 2B and the version you
see now uh they put that sound effect
back now in the Spanish version it's a
much closer shot
um and you can see Dracula in the coffin
like that and they actually show Van
Helsing like in a fairly close shot with
a big stake like that like and he puts
it on Dracula's chest and raises the
thing like he's gonna hit it and then
they cut away so it's a lot more I mean
they still don't show it obviously
because it was 1931 and they can't share
that kind of [ __ ] better than the
English version it is still not enough
it's not enough but like I said they
couldn't get away with anything like
that that's what I mean it's like yeah
it would have been cool if they put the
whole thing about Lucy in there because
that was in the book like them doing all
that [ __ ] up [ __ ] to her body but in
1931 there was no way they could have
showed there should have been some kind
of a fight scene
you know some way of them forcing
Dracula into the casket you know either
he tries to come back out or they fight
Frozen man there hadn't been something
more more gags more people with crosses
you know forcing him in or something
it's just it's just too simple in both
in both of them it's too easy
yeah that's I think in the book I'm
trying to think like in the book I think
there was like a Chase and then was it
God it's been such a long time since I
read the book I thought it was Quincy
Morris
that staked him or maybe it was a couple
of them staking it but there was like
kind of like a Chase and the sun was
coming up and all this other kind of
[ __ ] I don't think that Dracula popped
out his coffin if I remember correctly
but I don't know maybe he did maybe he
did fight back but yeah any kind of one
that just has him like finding I mean
because the whole thing was oh they just
have to find where he's hiding his
coffin at which to me seems like it
wouldn't be all that difficult he just
had it laying out and he opened that's
what I mean it would be a lot different
if
um you know he really had it hidden
something yes and then like the whole
thing would be like this mystery like
trying to figure out where it was just
should have been hidden in a wall behind
some kind of secret yeah see I mean if I
was if I was Dracula I would have like
all kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] to hide that
yeah you wouldn't be able to find me you
can't just like leave it out in the
middle of the floor because that seems
like where it was well obviously it
wasn't even blocked there it is
you can think you'd lock it from the
inside any [ __ ] could just like
wander down in there and be like oh hey
and it's like they know you can't get up
because the Sun's Up and you just have
to like lay there and be like well again
staked that sucks I want to move some of
those blocks out of the castle and made
a damn tunnel and got in there and had
equipment to pull the blocks in behind
me you don't mention there'd be no way
and also put a lock on the coffin just
for just for more safety on the inside
sure put some alarms out there
yeah well I mean it's like nowadays you
could have all kind of [ __ ] you could
have like your cell phone you could have
a ring doorbell
you know it's like you could he could
just like have a tablet in the coffin
and be like hey some [ __ ]
outside my hook you know what I mean do
you have anything else on it uh let me
see hold on
um slash Fred said there's a foreign
company called uh Bollywood who has done
their own versions of many famous movies
including yeah I mean well I kind of
feel like India they do maybe not as
many as turkey I feel like turkey is
kind of for doing
um just really really cheap
shitty versions of pretty much any movie
that did any did any any bit of business
but India does that too yeah just look
up turkey Turkish Spider-Man Turkish
Batman Turkish Star Wars they're on
YouTube they're [ __ ] horrible
funny though well they're funny because
it's supposed to be funny it's funny
because
um of the way that different things are
translated through different cultures
which one is it is it Turk Spider-Man or
Turkish Batman that has him go into like
a strip club and like killing people and
[ __ ] Turkish Spider-Man I think that's
turkey Spider-Man was a bad guy actually
yeah you couldn't conceive from
Spider-Man being a good guy
not looking like that
well Batman's kind of the same way some
some
I've seen Japan kind of ripped off
Batman and they would make villains look
like Batman like the villains from
[ __ ] what was it G-Force yeah from
G-Force was Batman it looked like Batman
drawings just like him but
you know so anything it looks like that
has to be a bad guy you would think
yeah yeah that's really that's an
interesting cultural kind of thing yeah
yeah it's like if you don't want to
watch the whole movies
um Brandon tenold who is a Canadian
YouTuber and he's [ __ ] hilarious he
does a lot of those he talks a lot about
those Turkish knockoff movies
um and he does like 20 30 minute like
breakdowns of them and some of them are
just like unbelievable
unbelievable
um one of these days says slasher Fred
you should review the film The Fearless
Vampire Killers I would like to do that
one that's uh that's Roman Polanski
right did not remember playing Fearless
Vampire Killers is he in that why am I
thinking that I don't know Danny Rowling
said instead of uh shake and bake it's
steak and bake let's take him and watch
him catch fire that's the thing I do
kind of feel like and that's
honestly I think the the kind of
anti-climactic ending of both and like I
said in that regard the Spanish version
is better it's still not great but at
least you see what's happening I think
the English language version like I said
it's just oh there's van helsing's back
way the [ __ ] over there and then we're
cutting away and you kind of know you
know what happened because it's implied
but they don't show it you know what I
mean so but you know I like I said that
was the time it was the 1930s you can't
show a stake going into a chest you
can't show somebody getting their head
cut off you can't show anything like
that I mean there's so much [ __ ] you
can't show well [ __ ] like in the English
language version they couldn't even show
him biting anyone you know actually the
Spanish language version they don't show
him biting anyone either like a few
times but he does get kind of closer
like he'll lean over and then like he'll
do his cape but they did show Mina or
Eva biting uh John slash Juan they did
show her doing that like or at least
like going for his neck and be like I
like that so that was more like way more
than the English language version showed
so there was that I mean they're both
either they're both totally worth
watching because and it's really cool to
like watch them really close together so
you can like compare because it's like I
said it was the same exact script they
worked out the same exact script in some
ways I think the Spanish filmmakers it
was directed by um George Milford by the
way who didn't speak any Spanish she had
to have a um he actually started as an
actor he was in some movies with
Valentino and [ __ ] but um he was in a
[ __ ] in a movies and directed A [ __ ]
into movies but he had to have a
translator because he didn't speak any
Spanish but he did a bunch of these so
um I mean the funny thing was that I
guess in a way they kind of had an
advantage because they would come in at
night and then they would watch the
dailies from Todd Browning's version and
then they'd be like how can we do that
but better you know what I mean it's
like oh well they're just keeping the
camera in this one place we're gonna do
like create some crazy [ __ ] with it it's
not crazy but I mean it was a lot more
Dynamic like I said than the English
language version because they already
had a template to go off of and they
said how can we approve that so in some
scenes they absolutely did now I met say
that Bella Lugosi you can't beat that
role like I said he owns that [ __ ] but
most of the other things about and I
like the Van Helsing and the English
language version I like some things
better about the English language
version but on most other metrics I
think in a lot of ways the Spanish
language version is better so do I think
other than Bella Lugosi if Bella Lugosi
had been in the Spanish language version
that would have been like the best
Dracula movie ever yeah
even though I gotta give respect to the
to Carlos Carlos did a good draft he did
a good vampire
it's not Bill Legos I mean that guy's
iconic yeah
he did that [ __ ] live for years before
he ever did it in a movie
so he kind of
he kind of wrote what you know of as a
as Dracula you know that was kind of his
role you know kind of like how Leonard
Nimoy basically wrote Spock yeah all the
[ __ ] that you remember about Spock
that was his baby yeah so um
they're both great movies uh for
different reasons the Spanish version
I'm going to give the Spanish version
for being it's a better story there's
more of it there
it's a more Innovative movie them
they're moving the camera around it's a
lot more fun to watch
the acting style is retro for 1931 which
that makes sense to me you know I mean
it's still it's just got a slightly
different tone
um
the guy playing Dracula is not doing uh
he's not doing a Lugosi style vampire
he's
he's doing his own interpretation of it
and it's closer to kind of like
Nosferatu if you ask me if you can
imagine Nosferatu speaking that's kind
of what you're dealing with I like it
though yeah I like it they're both
really funny but like I said watch them
both like as a double feature it's like
really interesting yeah slasher Fred
said there was once cereals that had
versions of Dracula and Frankenstein
called chocolate and Frankenberry yeah
everybody knows about that actually I
think they still make it I saw them I
saw them at Sam's or Costco or something
like that like around Halloween yeah
booberry I don't think that one and they
had fruit brute too yeah I remember that
you remember fruit Brew you don't
remember I don't think that one sold all
that well but I think they still do them
in I don't know if they sell them all
year but I think they do like limited
editions around Halloween I don't really
like I like the idea of it but the
cereals themselves I don't think I don't
remember them tasting goody when I was a
kid no I I don't I didn't like them
either yeah well I just like the boxes
right like I thought I was like man why
isn't the cereal good it made me so mad
because I was like I would totally buy
this because the boxes are awesome I
remember blueberry was like [ __ ]
sweet as [ __ ] yeah super sweet and I
think I think the uh
the strawberry one that had Frankenstein
on it what was that called Frankenberry
Frankenberry yeah I remember that kind
of like tearing up my tongue
there's something about that in some
ways well well yeah was it the dye or
was it kind of like Captain Crunch where
it has like where it's that real
textured I think it might have been a
little bit of both it gives you like
little micro Cuts yeah like on your
tongue I think it was the dye yeah it
might have been there's something about
that red dye that I wonder was that a
funny taste I wonder was that the red
dye that got banned later on it might be
like that it had been on the M Ms or
whatever the only one that I remember
when I was a kid that I haven't seen in
a long time that I thought was great was
a dab Cookie Crisp cereal remember that
I think they still make that yeah I
haven't seen it a long time that [ __ ]
was delicious he likes that too yeah one
now one cereal that I think they still
make it I don't know we don't buy a lot
of cereal so I wouldn't and I don't
really go in the cereal aisle so I don't
know but I used to really like Cookie
Crisp too one cereal but I don't know if
they still make it one cereal that I'm
almost positive they don't make any more
but I used to love as a kid was waffles
I remember those yeah God those were
delicious yeah we're talking about food
they were Maple they were Maple oh they
were so good I remember them yeah
American Military 100 have you guys ever
reviewed the omen Trilogy we did didn't
we didn't we do all the omen movies we
have to check we've seen them all I
don't know if we reviewed them I
remember we watched them like a year and
a half ago and I was like I thought we
had done like all three of them like
over three days it's one of the best
trilogies out there they're all good
they're all good and I kind of feel like
people don't talk about two and three
but they're both right and actually like
I love three a young Sam Neal is in the
third one I love a grown-up Damian I
love the three the final Conflict I
thought it was really cool the way it
ended and everything yeah they're all
good they're all good I mean the first
one is like my favorite because it's
iconic but you know and that kid is
[ __ ] great three was cool too but
they were all good they're all good
um Rebecca says count Cola was a thing
here when I was a kid in Australia uh
Cola soda soft drink with Count Dracula
the kid I don't remember that that's
pretty awesome yeah I don't think we had
that here unfortunately Danny rolling oh
this is a blast from the past there used
to be these black vampire popsicles in
the early 90s that would turn your
tongue black with blood filling I
remember those I don't remember that I
remember that
um vampire secret popsicles yep I
remember those I think we had those a
couple times I remember the black ice
cream used to get a Baskin Robbins for
uh oh yeah for Halloween it was black
licorice they would sell black licorice
ice cream and pumpkin ice cream pumpkin
ice cream yeah it's good maybe we should
all with all that pumpkin that we had
maybe we should make some ice cream with
it man making ice cream so expensive
nowadays be cheaper to order that flavor
probably it would because you need all
the eggs and all the cream and all that
we yeah we I could probably I could go
down to Sam's probably get all that
cream it makes a lot of cream yeah a lot
of cream we used to have an ice cream I
don't have the ice cream maker yeah I
mean you know you can rig one up I mean
you can make it in a bag with a bunch of
ice and [ __ ] rocks yeah yeah it's not
hard yeah you don't need like the ice
cream maker yeah I could probably do it
with a damn probably do it with a uh
immersion blender
or egg beater yeah yeah you probably
probably you probably could you get kind
of thick
you know what that machine's probably
not expensive you want me to get a
machine don't you
I'm gonna you know what else she wants
me to make she wants me to make a still
when did I say that I just I just made
you say that because
I want to make a stick that's how we're
gonna play because I was like I
literally cannot remember ever saying
that to you in the 12 or 13 years yeah
unless that was so drunk and I don't
remember
still make a still make moonshine or or
vodka that's really funny yeah
Rebecca also says Interview with a
Vampire is still my favorite vampire
film original Nosferatu is my second uh
also good films honestly I don't know if
I could pick I'm probably the hunger uh
you know the Lost Boys
I don't know I like a lot of the I just
I don't know I like a lot of them so
it's kind of hard to like pick just one
Spanish Dracula man check it out it's
free it's good yeah it's good yeah like
I said but the both versions are on
there yeah and the thing it's a bonus
movie slasher Fred said one of the
classic movies I have seen oh I've been
wanting to do this is mad monster party
like stop-motion animation I've been
wanting to do I might do it over on my
scare Salon thing because I've been
wanting to rewatch I haven't seen it in
years and years and I used to [ __ ]
love that and I haven't seen it for
probably 20 30 years and I really really
want to re-watch it so thank you for
reminding me because I might do that
like next month
uh American Military 100 said The Omen
was the only classic for who sequels
lived up to the original they were all
great yeah I agree what's tomorrow's a
haunting episode going to be well you
asked us to do ghost hunter we could do
that and that was one I think you
requested it before because I wrote it
down
so if nobody else has if nobody has any
objections then uh we'll do ghost hunter
uh and we can talk about that one
tomorrow so that'll be fun and then like
on Tuesday's matinee show we're doing uh
the sequel to Universal's Dracula which
is Dracula's daughter
now I will say that last night we
watched son of Dracula
and we might talk about that one too but
I didn't love it that one was Lon Chaney
you know yeah and I don't know are you
talking about the one last night son of
Dracula yeah soundtrack it wasn't any
good I didn't really like it no Lon
Chaney was not cast correctly in that
that's not who you wanted in there to be
Bill lugosi's son but Dracula's daughter
I kind of dug
it's kind of like more you said this is
almost like a chick flick it is a chick
flick kinda I like a chicken but it's
still good I like it I liked it too I
thought it was really cool I had seen it
before but I hadn't seen it for a really
long Dracula's daughter said she's kind
of a repentant vampire she doesn't want
to be a vampire anymore so she hires she
basically kind of hooks up with a
psychiatrist or a psychologist she
thinks she thinks that he
can make her back into a mortal it
doesn't really work out though it
doesn't work out spoiler alert
he's got a she's a good looking chick
looks like a [ __ ] Greek statue of
Hera or something low-cut outfit and
then there's bodies in the movie you
know and um it's in a modern setting
it'll probably they're probably in New
York somewhere huh did they ever say
where they are oh I don't know now I
have to like look it up I can't remember
yeah it's not out in any spooky castles
or anything like that yeah it's that
like in a modern thing yeah well modern
for 1936 or whenever it came out there's
kind of hints of lesbianism in it yes
they're doing some Carmella actually
yeah you did a little bit of Carmella
action
it was ahead of his time well I think
you were just supposed to read in
between lines that something was up but
um
no it's a pretty good flick I I wouldn't
worry about dragging the sun [ __ ] that
son of dragons
um but Dracula's daughter is good we'll
do we'll talk about it we'll talk about
that Tuesday because tomorrow we gotta
do haunting but yeah so tomorrow like I
said we're probably gonna do ghost
hunter unless some other thing
intervenes which I probably won't uh but
I'll announce it again tomorrow so you
guys if you want to watch it like prior
to us talking about it so you know
that'll be fun so uh thanks everybody
for dropping by and hanging out with us
talking about Spanish language Dracula
and all that kind of stuff and have a
good rest of your evening and we'll see
you guys again for haunting Mondays
tomorrow good night